[Música]
cuántas veces hemos dejado decir a
nuestros papás lo que realmente soñamos
estudiar o hacer en nuestras vidas pues
simplemente cuántas veces hemos dejado
de hacerles a llamar a la persona que
nos ha gustado por mucho tiempo pero no
nos hemos atrevido a decirle alguna vez
te has puesto a pensar cuántas veces
restringimos nuestro propio progreso a
veces somos nosotros mismos quienes nos
imponemos obstáculos y barreras que nos
impiden avanzar y luchar en función de
algún objetivo en particular
cuántas veces no hemos querido enviarle
ese correo a la persona que admiramos o
pedir esa cita en la empresa en la que
soñamos trabajar
cuántas veces nos dejamos ganar de la
pereza el miedo la timidez o cualquier
otro factor que simplemente se convierte
en un obstáculo mental y que hace que
nosotros mismos no vemos estos pasos en
la vida
fue hace más o menos un año cuando yo me
di cuenta que estaba en una de estas
situaciones un claro ejemplo en donde me
iba a imponer un obstáculo que me va a
impedir alcanzar un objetivo en
particular
acababa de terminar de leer un libro que
me movió de forma especial que me
inspiró y uno que definitivamente me
hizo un llamado a tomar acción
todos podemos cambiar el mundo es el
título de este libro escrito por juan
david aristizábal un joven emprendedor
colombiano que se ha destacado por sus
proyectos de impacto global y que sin
duda alguna ha transformado la vida de
muchos en este país
definitivamente una persona de admirar
que como consecuencia ha sido reconocido
en múltiples ocasiones por diferentes
medios tanto nacionales como
internacionales
debido a que yo estaba desarrollando
unos proyectos en zonas rurales del país
y gracias a mis ambiciones y objetivos
de vida fue que me senté y
particularmente identificado e inspirado
por juan david y de allí nacieron mis
ganas mi motivación y mi idea algo loca
de escribirle un correo
contándole un poco acerca de mí y
hablándole de lo identificado e
inspirado que me había sentido con él y
con su libro
fue esta idea de escribirle un correo a
juan david uno de esos momentos en los
cuales yo mismo casi apagó mi llama de
motivación uno de esos momentos en los
que pensé en no enviar ese correo
y no perder mi tiempo e incluso en tener
un cierto sentimiento de pena y temor
no obstante y gracias a que mi
motivación sobrepasaba todos estos
factores fue que me dije a mí mismo
pues que pierde
y no fue un pues que pierdo de esos que
simplemente se quedan en nuestra
imaginación sino que fue uno que me hizo
tomar acción y que eventualmente me
impulsó a escribir este correo
este es un claro ejemplo de una
situación en donde yo puede sobrepasar
mis obstáculos y mis barreras las cuales
muchas veces son fuente de nuestra
imaginación y las cuales muchas veces
son una herramienta que todos nosotros
usamos de forma implícita para quedarnos
dentro de esta zona de confort y no
arriesgarnos
fue gracias a ese impulso de motivación
que hice clic en el botón de enviar
más o menos dos semanas después de forma
muy inesperada y espontánea recibí una
respuesta por parte de juan david y su
equipo de trabajo yo no podía creer que
juan había leyó mi correo y mejor aún me
está invitando una reunión para que nos
pudiésemos conocer más a fondo
desde entonces y gracias a un simple
correo he tenido la posibilidad de
trabajar junto con juan david en
diferentes proyectos y juntos estamos
buscando construir nuestros objetivos de
vida y ayudar a la población colombiana
por medio del emprendimiento la
innovación y la tecnología
este ha sido un año lleno de muchos
aprendizajes de conocer a nuevas
personas y asimismo darle un mayor norte
a mis proyectos y aspiraciones
haber sobrepasado mis obstáculos y mis
barreras y haber tenido el coraje y la
determinación de escribir y enviar este
correo fue una experiencia que me dejó
muchos aprendizajes y enseñanzas
primero que todo me pude dar cuenta que
todo está a nuestro alcance cuando había
era una persona que yo lo tenía en lo
más alto como si fuese inalcanzable
hoy en día sigo admirando a juan de la
misma forma pero hoy esta persona que yo
pensaba que era inalcanzable es el mismo
con el cual ahora me escribo y hablo
frecuentemente
esta experiencia me hizo entender que
realmente intentar no cuesta nada y que
para llegar a nuestros objetivos incluso
es cuestión de un poco de probabilidad
veamos
si uno nunca ha estos pasos y si yo
nunca hubiese enviado mi correo entonces
mi probabilidad de haber llegado a
conocer a juan david hubiese sido nula e
inexistente
pues nadie tiene por qué saber quiénes
somos nosotros si uno mismo no se
manifiesta al enviar ese correo hacer
esa llamada pedir esa cita o simplemente
dar ese paso son factores que nos van a
permitir estar más cerca de nuestro
objetivo final esto no garantiza que lo
vamos a lograr pero sí garantiza que
nuestras probabilidades van a aumentar
al enviar mi correo cuando por lo menos
ya tenía una señal mía ya sabía que yo
lo estaba buscando y entonces la
probabilidad de que él me contestara iba
a aumentar ya que mi manifestación era
real y tangible
esta experiencia también me hizo
entender la importancia de tanto buscar
ayuda como asimismo volverse una fuente
de ayuda y servicio hacia los demás me
hizo entender que brindar ayuda tiene la
misma importancia y relevancia de aquel
que busca esa ayuda y entonces sí todos
adoptamos esa mentalidad de servirle a
los demás le perdemos el miedo tanto a
buscar como a brindar ayuda podemos
crear estas increíbles cadenas de
favores en donde se genere una sinergia
que logre romper con todos los
obstáculos y barreras que cada uno de
nosotros se impone ya que todos vamos a
estar trabajando en función de tanto
brindar ayuda como también de buscar
ayuda de otros
y esto suena muy lindo en papel y muy
enriquecedor pero la realidad es que la
única forma de comenzar es con que cada
uno de nosotros de estos pasos en la
vida que nos propongamos en buscar esa
ayuda que necesitamos sin que nosotros
mismos nos frenemos en el proceso en
brindarles ayuda genuina a aquel que nos
está buscando y más que nada en
arriesgarnos y en darnos cuenta que
realmente intentar no cuesta nada y que
un pequeño acto puede dar frutos
inimaginables
esto es como cuando uno pone un hámster
a correr dentro de una de esas ruedas de
plástico una vez el animal da el primer
paso después no hay nadie quien lo pare
con nosotros creo que sucede lo mismo
una vez damos ese primer paso después no
hay nadie quien nos pare y de un pequeño
acto se puede desencadenar una serie de
experiencias y oportunidades que nunca
antes nos hubiésemos imaginado al enviar
mi correo no solamente puede conocer a
juan david también puede conocer a
muchas otras personas que me han ayudado
a volver mis metas una realidad
pude comenzar mi propio podcast con la
ayuda a diferentes organizaciones
pude entrevistar a emprendedores de
talla mundial e incluso tuve la
oportunidad de ser invitado a una
entrevista en una de las estaciones de
radio más importantes del país donde
pude exponer un proyecto que yo había
acabado de lanzar y que tiene como
objetivo ayudar a financiar a los micro
emprendedores del país
todo un mundo de experiencias y
oportunidades se abrió ante mis ojos al
dar un pequeño pero significativo paso
considero que aún me falta muchísimo por
vivir aprender y conocer pero creo
firmemente que igual que el hámster que
corre sin parar nosotros también podemos
dar esos pasos que nos permitan [ __ ] la
atracción y las fuerzas necesarias para
cambiar el camino a nuestras vidas y
ayudarnos a moldear una nueva realidad
que vaya acorde a nuestros propósitos y
objetivos a largo plazo
pero lo mejor de todo es que me di
cuenta y descubrí que todo esto que
acabo de decir
ya lo sabía
igual que probablemente ustedes también
al fin y al cabo esto no es ciencia
nuclear pero lo que no sabía y los
invito a explorar es que me di cuenta
que al tomar acción al dar estos pasos y
al no dejar todo esto como simplemente
un aprendizaje teórico
realmente podemos hacer que las cosas
sucedan podemos pasar de la planeación a
la acción en cuestión de segundos y al
dar estos pasos que por más pequeños o
insignificantes que parezcan tal y como
enviar un correo
realmente podemos lograr resultados
extraordinarios que por más cliché que
suene logren cambiar el camino a
nuestras vidas y nuestro pensamiento
frente a diferentes temas de una u otra
forma
y aunque esta es una simple y humilde
experiencia sin duda alguna que fue un
evento que transformó mi camino de vida
y más que nada que me hizo entender el
poder que tenemos en nuestras manos para
moldear y ser los arquitectos de nuestro
propio futuro
por eso hoy los invito a que envíen ese
correo que tienen pendiente que hagan
esa llamada que nos han atrevido a hacer
que le cuenten a sus papás lo que
realmente sueñan estudiar o hacer en sus
vidas
o que simplemente le digan esas palabras
a la persona que siempre la han querido
hablar y aún no lo han hecho
intentar no cuesta nada y como dije
anteriormente si queremos llegar a
nuestros objetivos es cuestión de una
simple probabilidad así que usemos esta
estadística a nuestro favor
hagamos que las cosas sucedan tenemos el
poder en nuestras manos ahora sólo falta
ponerlo en práctica
y como dijo el fundador de facebook
marck septiembre el mayor riesgo es no
tomar ningún riesgo y en un mundo que
está constantemente cambiando el único
camino que garantiza impedir nuestro
propio desarrollo es no intentar así que
juntos hagamos que las cosas sucedan y
que nuestros intentos se conviertan en
el mayor motor de desarrollo y
crecimiento personal muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]